[Music]
the sinoff doesn't mean much but I do
want to recognize Rick and Morty for
providing a well-placed trigger warning
at the top of the episode however and
unfortunately I'm giving it right back
for not putting the same warning at the
top of episode 2 which also had a
graphic suicide big a lane guys do you
care or not who's ready for Rick's
famous spaghetti I have never once throw
my phone at a wall and had it snap clean
in half like this I can't even imagine
what it would need to be made out of in
order for it to break this way I feel
like I'm going to be distracted by this
for the rest of the episode because
there's nothing weirder they could
possibly put in front of my eyes right I
love spaghetti Thursday spaghetti
Thursdays this food plus day of the week
naming technique does not follow the
very important rule of the first letter
in each word matching you can have
spaghetti Saturdays or even spaghetti
Sundays Thursdays are reserved for tuna
totinos or talcum powder it's better to
just not ask about that last one that
was a dark time look Leonardo D Vinci
invented some cool sh but even he was
unable to invent a way to serve up such
a perfect portion of spaghetti and
bologan in one scoop Grandpa Rick I am
skull emoji but words oh is that how
you'd prefer we did this summer well I
am and most importantly but words too
God no why why no why is it always this
with you of course it's a person Morty
has every right to be mad but he's also
a dumbass for missing several red flags
here firstly he seems oblivious to the
fact that spaghetti Thursday starts with
an open corpse in the garage that we can
see is easy to stumble upon secondly
Rick clearly hasn't been using the
kitchen so where did he think the
spaghetti making was happening thirdly
and most red Flagg isly not questioning
the fact that Rick decided to do
something nice for the family either
this planet is Tiny with huge buildings
or regular sized withing huge buildings
and either option seems like an odd and
burdensome architectural choice on this
planet people that kill themselves turn
into spaghetti is a thing I have to try
and be funny about without making it
seem like I've missed the joke subtext
or multi-layered metaphor in other words
another day sending Rick and Morty it's
almost better cold wouldn't go that far
don't be a hipster there's not enough
irony weird mustaches or hats involved
for this to be something hipsters do I'm
calling the police before you do that
just Rick what where am I Super Genius
Rick does this I just want to be honest
about something after Lawrence died we
uh ate him we're supposed to believe
Morty's doing this to clear his
conscience but if he has a conscience
how can he not see how unconscionable it
is to say this at the poor man's funeral
the show seems to want to have its
spaghetti and make its characters aone
for it too and I just want to let them
eat cake what doesn't make any sense
this episode is weird and it's making me
weirder so we were eating people wait a
second earlier Morty said I want their
names I'm telling Mom Rick held up his
end of the bargain so why the are we
suddenly telling the whole family
instead of moving on to something
Lessing weird like a character called Mr
Poopy butthole hard to put out of your
mind yes which is why I thought it best
to keep you all in the dark well then
why did you bring the entire fing body
home with you why can't you harvest the
spaghetti on Spaghetti planet and then
bring it home in Tupperware containers
how does Rick not have Tupperware just
keep eating them we can't now because of
you sorry Morty that was terrible
parenting
oh man here now really after seven
seasons this is where you decide your
parenting has crossed the line into
terrible you are invited to 41 Kepler B
you know it as spaghetti Planet you're
not in trouble we just want to talk
Morty chooses to believe this random
sentient spaceship and let it take him
to 41 Kepler B just because the
spaceship speaks the truth doesn't make
it any less stupid that Morty goes along
with all of this we're all very special
and different but we we definitely all
do like spaghetti we do not let me guess
you went back to the planet gave some
thoughtful insight to their leader and
now they're selling their dad at every
space Walmart the sad realization that
if we ever did start colonizing other
planets there would most assuredly be
some Walmarts on said planets is this
people or not people I just need to know
how much I should pretend to be upset I
love it when Rick and Morty use their
irreverent format to challenge the big
Topics in society topics like do we
really want to know where our food comes
from wrapped up in a right to die
metaphor among others it's good 10 out
of 10 what I don't love is using Jerry
to say the quiet part out loud and
stripping away all the Nuance out of the
metaphor for the benefit of the real
world Jerry's in the back row don't
Pander to the Jerry's they're not
listening anyway I was a serial killer
in Cannibal and now I get to kill myself
and be food for you this company's
building a fing hologram into every can
and that is an expense they really
didn't need to bother with the only
marketing most people need is the word
organic and a quick quote about how the
recipe came from Uncle Roy in the 1920s
like oh here was a of racist but damn it
he knew how to make a good spaghetti
none of this would have happened if
you'd been honest about the spaghetti
regardless of when Rick told Morty where
the spaghetti came from Morty would
still feel ethically obligated to fix
spaghetti plan's Problems by making a
thousand more problems for Rick to solve
okay so we just need to figure out
something else besides people to put in
the cans right can't you just in hear me
out now because this might sound a
little weird can't you just use actual
Earth spaghetti I love you clone 5617
I guess all clone stories turn out the
same way I mean the island didn't really
they cloned Tyrone certainly didn't and
neither did Star Wars Attack of the
Clones as much as we wish it probably
had it's in horrible unimaginable pain
from the moment it's born oh jeez oh no
Rick so I didn't even bother to make it
because I knew you'd take issue all
right stop the car so Rick came up with
an idea abandon it gave the abandoned
idea cell also he could show the
abandoned idea to Morty so that he could
tell him he abandoned the idea he knew
he wouldn't approve of I do not believe
Rick had the time or will for this maybe
give them a claw like hand so they can
you know stab themselves to death but
why are you assuming they would want to
stab themselves to death if this
existence is all they've known why would
you assume they want it to end dunk
beetles literally spend their entire
lives in but you don't see them
deliberately drowning themselves in feal
matter do you it's more believable to me
that Rick was able to clone the
spaghetti filed torsos than being able
to set up a system that even distributes
the spaghetti to the
cans where are you you're going to blow
yourself up I know they're trying to
find logic and the instinctual need for
society to polarize every topic is a big
ask but if these guys are fighting for
the rights of the torsos then why are
they going to blow them up isn't that
killing more torsos shouldn't they be
trying to free the
torsos Rick Morty and the president of
the spaghetti Planet survived this
what's the going to hold up I've got an
entire planet waiting on delivery when
the spaghetti delivery ships left
earlier no one was out here trying to
get to the planet where were all of you
then did you have a like a youthanasia
chamber ready to go Morty isn't doing so
great on the won't ask questions promise
he made earlier when Rick decided to
help him clean up this mess skip yep
we're skipping the whole emotional
finale Montage thing solid point was
being made about would you still eat
bacon if you were friends with the pig
debate but it's presented through this
manufactured and emotionally
manipulative life story that is several
notches of up beyond what the inside out
Critters in my brain can handle look if
you really want to see what happens fine
but it'll be through the lens of me
nitpicking some of the pettiest possible
to offset the profoundness of the
subject matter swapping gum is gross
this jersey just says sports ball this
trophy is for a skill set that is far
too specific to be worthy of Celebration
not everyone can be a winner and
pedaling this idea leads to unrealistic
expectations and pressures our kids to
always be the best when statistically
that is not possible these Frozen people
who all stopped M Applause math this
working lava lamp isn't plugged into any
anything driving in the passing Lane
with no intention of passing anyone
using your nose picking ass digging
digits instead of aing spoon are you all
happy now bone appe
Petit more vomit again after last
episode doesn't even make sense this
time tears I understand but why does it
always have to be vomit I swear Rick and
Morty I will back to back bonus
roundhouse kick you into Triple S digits
and don't you think I won't you couldn't
change everyone's taste buds but you
could make it just tasteful but how will
this help them with all the people that
have ordered spaghetti but aren't
currently on the planet to see this it's
a nice cinamon especially for Rick and
Morty but does it make the fact that it
works any less bullshitty holy this
is the best Salsbury steak I've ever had
the best Salsbury steak you've ever had
still equals a prettying gross meal so
I'm not buying anyone's excitement here
is it actually Salsbury steak do you
want to know or not no thanks woo
because the secret is that Salsbury
steak wasn't named after Salsbury
England but after some dude called
Salsbury who lived in Missouri that's
right you're eating Missouri fooders
just when we thought this episode
couldn't get any
grosser hey it feels like C spaghetti
you guys it feels like C spaghetti
that's some good spaghetti that accent
is terrible Rick I I got to know like
what's the secret ingredient silent is
fever what is that smell do you like
bisetti but it's not too late to repent
your sins but first let's pass the
collection
plate good afternoon to everyone I'm
Kenny Powers if you're here and you're
someone Shane cared about someone Shane
loved or maybe you're just somebody who
has no business being here at all who's
just here because you think it's going
to make you more popular like
Ivan
not a sort of an oy afterbirth and would
you consider yourself a typical earthian
what's typical give me typical give me
some tip help me Obi-Wan Kenobi you're
my only hope but we can fix it right
Rick no there's no we This Time Pal